Поки антикорупційні органи в Україні замість того,
щоб боротися з відмиванням грошей,
погрузли в чварах одне з одним,
у Німеччині до журналістських викриттів офшорних
схем у панамських досьє поставилися серйозно.
Ось уже майже півроку, як у Кельні запрацювало
ось це відомство - у цілковитій секретності.
Тут працюють сто працівників, серед них - колишні
співробітники митниці, екс-банківські службовці, екс-бізнесмени.
Їхні імена не можна розголошувати, так само
як і показувати обличчя.
Нове відомство називається Financial Intelligence Unit
або "фінансова розвідка".
Звучить як назва нової секретної служби.
Розповідаючи про мету створення відомства,
його шеф читає з аркуша.
Оскільки не хоче сказати нічого зайвого.
Мета відмивання грошей - приховати від держави
нелегально придбані активи.
Щоб виявити подібні випадки серед мільйонів
легальних транзакцій і бізнес-операцій,
необхідно вміти проводити аналіз, розуміти
фінансові взаємозв'язки і мати деяку інтуїцію.
Для відмивання грошей використовуються не тільки
казино, ресторани і дрібний бізнес.
Дедалі частіше зловмисники
використовують операції з нерухомістю.
Тож банки зобовязують повідомляють про підозрілі
транзакції до нового відомства.
За словами Андреаса Бардонґа, Німеччина дедалі
частіше стає майданчиком для відмивання грошей.
І мета його підлеглих - перевірка інформації
про підозри у відмиванні грошей.
Якщо ці підозри підтвердяться, "Фінансова розвідка"
передає дані далі - слідчим.
До кінця року відомство поповниться ще
50-тьма новими співробітниками.
Щоправда, критики, приміром, у
Transparency International, вважають:
створення нового відомства - це профанація.
На їхню думку, Німеччина дуже мляво бореться
з відмиванням грошей, і є раєм
для податкових ухильників.
На цю тему голова нового відомства говорити не хоче.
Додає лише, що вважає, що в Німеччині чимало
зроблено для боротьби з відмиванням коштів.